gehen wir in die ukraine gehen wir zu
peter hell nach kiew wo die sirenen
geheult haben und peter du bist dort im
dunkeln ihr dürft kein licht machen
damit scharfschützen euch nicht sehen
können
das ist richtig wir uns jetzt auf ganz
herunter gedimmt wir hören im
hintergrund bombeneinschläge ich weiß
nicht ob ihr das sehen könnt das ist der
norden falls man überhaupt ein paar
lichter sieht sie können ganz schön habt
können wir die kirche sehen die bei euch
in der nähe ist
ja genau die kirche und dahinter was man
von hier aus leider nicht sehen kann da
fängt die stadt an das ist der norden
wir haben dort gerade sehr häufig
einschläge gehört dass es ihnen sind die
außenbezirke wohl jetzt gekämpft wird
das geht jetzt los im mit dem eintritt
der dunkelheit bewegen sich die truppen
dann gibt es unterstützung von granaten
und von marschflugkörpern und das wird
uns wahrscheinlich den ganzen abend
begleiten wir haben hier in der hier in
der hauptstadt in kiew haben wir diese
ganzen entwicklung hier mit mit extremer
sorge und und auf verwunderung jetzt
geht wieder die sirene los ich will noch
mal kurz rüber zeigen das
geht jetzt die ganze zeit zu also wir
haben das mit verwunderung und ich will
das so kurz fertig machen die
die verhandlungen jetzt sind für uns im
prinzip eine art zeit schinden damit
russland seine truppen hier wieder neu
formieren kann denn die ukraine haben
ihn ganz
massive schläge zugeführt halt auch in
dem nachschub das heißt die russen
kommen überhaupt nicht nach hier das
heißt der flughafen ist auch wieder
zurückerobert worden in ost doppel und
das ist genau der brückenkopf den
bräuchen die russen hier 10 km 15
kilometer vor kiew um überhaupt mit
nachschub einzugreifen also wir halten
hier auch die ukraine halten diese
verhandlungen so ein bisschen für eine
scharade dazu passt natürlich dann
direkt diese art und weise der
eskalation mit der drohung den den den
verteidigungs zustand atom verteidigungs
zustand wieder auf aufrecht zu erhalten
von wladimir putin also das sind für uns
ja alles in sachen potent ische dörfer
das funktioniert und ich wir glauben
hier dass die ukrainische armee wirklich
in der lage ist diese russische armee zu
stoppen deswegen sie braucht ewigkeiten
oder braucht vier tage sie kommt
überhaupt nicht in die stadt rein und
die verteidigung ist so extrem dass wir
glauben dass putin einfach sich mit
dieser art von verhandlungen von dieser
taktiererei einfach bisschen ruhe
verschaffen will ich glaube wir müssen
jetzt runter hinter das sind
gespenstische bilder du dort im dunkeln
die ganze staaten schwarz und dem
hintergrund hören wir die sirenen heulen
vielleicht kannst du noch kurz sagen wir
wollen sich eigentlich die russischen
militärs die dort dann in die stadt
eingehen wie wollen die sich da zu recht
finden es wurden ja auch die straßen
schilder abgebaut die ganze stadt ist
dunkel
richtig das ist eine ganz spannende wenn
man das sagt
drinnen gewesen als zivilisten getan sie
haben markierungen angebracht leuchten
kreide es wurde schon hier der
bevölkerung sagt wenn ihr seht dass
irgendwas markiert wird deckt das ab das
sind solche sachen damit sie sich nicht
zurechtfinden oder damit sie sich
zurechtfinden sollen die russischen
einheiten die dann hier vordringen und
es wurden auch greift trupps hier
eingesetzt das heißt jeder der jetzt auf
der straße ist gilt im prinzip als feind
der schießbefehl ist eingesetzt worden
das heißt wenn ich jetzt auf die straße
geben würde ich würde sofort erschossen
werden wir am gerade hinter uns haben
noch leute gesehen die sind hinter einer
person her gerannt also das ist jetzt
eine art katz und maus spiel in
anführungsstrichen das ist nicht witzig
hier werden ziele markiert um dann für
einen angriff eben panzer und eben auch
lasergesteuerte waffen einsetzen zu
können mit der danke für diese
ausführung wirklich als dieser
gespenstischen stadt hier weil es gute
für diese nacht für euch bringt dich
jetzt mit den sicherheit